[Music]
please don't get involved
what is up thick fam it is monday
morning june 27th
oh man big week ufc 276
finally
finally we got ourselves a big boy
pay-per-view and i am so freaking
excited we also finally have a calabasas
fight companion for this big ass card as
well so that is this mother trucking
saturday baby
uh i can't wait man i can't wait this
card is stacked and we will get to that
shortly but um man i'm so excited i'm so
freaking excited you only got four
fights on the main card as of now
because misha's uh tate's fight was uh
cancelled lauren murphy had kovacs she
finally told everyone why she had to
i mean out of all the things like you
know yeah she's gonna be fine you know
god willing she's fine healthy girl so
at least that's one you could just
reschedule if they want i doubt they
find a
the week of replacement i bet you
there's behind the scenes i believe
there's a lot of girls putting their
hands up to fight meech i mean she's a
huge name huge name so i would you know
we love misha tate here you guys know
this we love misha tate so hopefully uh
it all works out for her but before we
get into this juicy thick ufc 276 main
card there are some fights over the
weekend kids so let's recap that really
quick and then we will get into all the
juicy breakdown of uc 276. you had a
great fight night i uh i was actually
i was able to watch some of the prelims
and then i had to do
a set and uh used to be called culver
city uh jam in the van
um different venue is off motor there
kind of i guess that
mar vista maybe i don't know but either
way um i was able to record uh the
fights and i watched it um at midnight
um and it did not disappoint it was a
fight night that was uh you know full of
monsters and great matchups um
this
fight night card had better matchups
this is this might surprise the casuals
but the fight night last saturday had
better stylistic fights more
equal fights better matchups than ufc
276. you'll see 276 is a lot of
mismatches
and not because the other fighters
aren't good or one guy's just that much
better it's just styles make fights and
in these uh main event or sorry main
card fights
a lot of it is favored towards the ufc
stars and we will get to that um
but that was not the case on the fight
night here because you had gamra versus
armin um
phenomenal fight to the highest level
lightweights on the planet going to add
it and uh your boy gamrot was down 0-2
in the first two rounds and then really
this fight was predicated off that third
round um you know depending scored that
but i definitely thought gamrat won this
fight stays on the fee i think he's 20-0
now um i don't think armin loses any um
you know momentum here i think both
these guys can get a big name fight next
it just shows you you know where these
guys are ranked uh and how deep 155 is
in the ufc it's insane these guys are so
goddamn good they're transitions they're
grappling they're striking i mean
they're good at everything dude they're
so freaking good so so good um so yeah i
think gamra he called out some some big
names i i think he asked for uh gaity
next um definitely don't think you're
getting that my man but you're
definitely getting a big fight next
definitely and so is armin like dude i
don't know who's gonna
i'll say this same thing keith dryden
told me after i lost my first fight
because i feel sorry for the af to fight
next would be the exact same thing i
tell army because that kid is so goddamn
skilled handsome bastard too armenian i
think but he trains out of dagestan
handsome bastard god damn dude
um great fight though really really
great good fight
on the other end in the co-main event
you had my boy neil magney who i
nicknamed the gazelle and he has changed
his nickname and i'm offended um but you
know neil magney's been a staple of the
welterweight division uh he's just kind
of been this
low-key dude who's setting records and
fight time and wins and stuff like that
but he's not flashy guy he's not gonna
you know do a hot promo into the mic so
uh he doesn't get the credit he deserves
um they they did him no favors in any
facet they they threw them to the
[ __ ] wolves when uh
chef cat
um
man this dude ah this dude if you're a
hamzap fan this dude is the next
same vibe as the homs out there this
dude is scary and what he did to neil
magne and the way he got it done
he's gonna be a prom man this kid is a
[ __ ] welterweight again
and uh 178 ufc is
jam-packed
it is jam-packed like the 405 in
california during rush hour it is
full of dope ass fighters talented
fighters from top to bottom because uh
shopcat i just i don't know
we haven't seen any um chinks in the
armor and you know neil magney is a big
one for him and he absolutely uh mopped
the floor with him and
you know i think he got on the mic and
he called out um uh nick diaz jory
mazdal
again those ain't happening my man you
know gamrak calls out uh
gaichi god bless you and these guys are
shooting for the for the moon they're
going to land on the stars uh
shofkat they're they're definitely i
could see them giving them wonderboy
again
the ufc is
you know
i would assume on their monday morning
meeting today
um shopkot is a guy they're going to
ride and die on you know like
his test was neil magney but i would be
willing to bet they were all secretly
cheering for shotgun you know magnus had
his run you know he's not a big draw
he's not a big you know um
i don't want to say fan favorites people
love neil but shopcat there's something
special there
and they want something special special
is what gets the big boy money sh uh the
the special guys that can check all
boxes like shopkot those special
fighters are the green elephant in this
circus when everybody's great and that
shop shopkot is a if you don't if you
guys haven't caught on his wave yet i'm
[ __ ] telling you this guy's a problem
so depending what they want to do with
them you have to beat neil magne
especially the way you beat him pretty
flawless victory yeah man i could see
wonder boy being next
and again with the ufc
if this is if wonder boy's a towel
they're ringing this thing out man
they're ringing this thing out
so you know you beat neil magne at 10.
um
you know he's ranked 15.
yeah you know yeah pierre fighting this
weekend which we'll get into um
[Music]
i i don't think you kill off two of your
young hungry lines especially that
philadelphia line and sean brady i don't
like that that would be stupid but you
never know what they're gonna do oh god
man after you beat ten
yeah wonder boy's right there
cynthia luca be a fantastic fight
i mean if you do shopkot
[Music]
yep
i mean it's insane good luck marking
that to americans shopkin hamzat
shafka hamzat
espn like wait what
yeah [ __ ] they're taking over i told
you guys
what shopcats uh background is what
i mean he's definitely from the same
area you know it's like
twos is a problem he puts on that hat
it's just [ __ ] over
um
this dude is oh my god
zubikistan uzbekistan uzbekistan
shirchi district uzbekistan
style [ __ ]
yeah yeah look at this [ __ ] kid
his girlfriend was ramen uh
uh had to take a surname with a local
flavor his father uh jesus christ this
dude is
chavez is from the anton bhai clan of
junior zeus uh i mean this is divergent
sister is also a memory fighter yeah no
[ __ ]
um i got just a [ __ ] problem man i
don't know what they're gonna do what
are they gonna do with this guy who the
[ __ ] gonna sign up to fight these guys
man
it's a problem
it's a goddamn
problem um yeah card was great from top
to bottom though really really fun
matchups uh
i would say the biggest story over the
weekend was our boy big dick energy
mousasi lost his fight and not only did
he lose but he got handled he got i i
was i would say he got kind of hurt
early on and then johnny uh eblam uh
just kind of
took it to him it was it was his fight
he never let gegard get you know started
and just kind of you know kind of
mollywhopped them for five rounds which
is damn you know very surprising even
though johnny's undefeated i you know
you shouldn't see this coming with a guy
like gagar because it's very rare gegard
gets out class like that you know uriah
hall did the spinning back kick into the
body hurt him but you know he had some
kind of damage he took uh when he was
fighting overseas and stuff like that
but other than that mousasi is such a
veteran it's very rare he just gets out
class like this
um so it might be a
you don't want to take anything away
from johnny because he actually did the
goddamn thing he's you know att
undefeated fighter so the kid's a
problem man um yeah for gay guard it has
to be a little disheartening you know
and his age
so hopefully the big dick energy comes
back but uh
yeah it was tough to watch gay guard
lose like that man very tough but uh
shout out to johnny man undefeated
fighter what's interesting about him is
he actually has a tie
towards one of the main fighters on uc
276 because to get ready for a gay guard
he trained with sean strickland the
training partner
so you gotta imagine
johnny going against guy like strickland
to get ready for gay guard was you know
tremendously helpful but then also
uh for strickland to have a guy like
johnny with his grappling and his
takedown ability um
you know strictly nice to to strike
he like strike but i'm sure you know
going with johnny defend the takedowns
but also to get johnny down you have to
get pretty creative you're not just
gonna shoot in for a single leg there's
gonna have to be some chain wrestling
some uh faint setups to to get the guy
down so that's gonna help strickland if
he fights smart it's a big if we'll get
into it that's a big if he fights smart
against pierre because he's going to
need it because pierre's striking is
second to none when it comes to the
welterweight division you're talking
about a guy who has um
you know
beat
izzy twice won by ko but i don't put too
much into that let's get into ufc 276.
i don't put too much into that you know
i i clearly
um you know alex pierra uh is getting
this shot against sean strickland
has he earned it no god no um
but there's a reason why they're doing
it because they need
um they need fresh meat for izzy because
after jared cannonaire
there's not a lot for him he's kind of
cleaned out the division so this alex
pierra like i told you has beat izzy
twice in kickboxing only um i do not
think he beats izzy in mma um but again
as i told you guys early on in this
episode is this ufc 276
is um
it's it's not mismatches it is i want to
describe as mismatches i would describe
it as perfect fights for the favorites
um
because with izzy jared cannon air now
can canon ear beat most of division yeah
yep yep matches up awful against izzy
awful matchup for him he you know he's
slow um
you know
it's such a very very tough matchup for
jared canada very tough matchup for him
it's a perfect fight for izzy to get to
get a finish and just to build his star
power for the ufc uh he can light jared
up like a christmas tree i i do think
people will be surprised how tough
[ __ ] jared cannoner is i think to be
a tougher fight than you think
izzy mentioned uh
that this is gonna be his uh
spider versus force griffin fight if you
remember that fight which kind of you
know outclassed some more athletic
pulled the matrix moves off you know is
this is a match-up whereas he could
probably get that done
the knock on izzy and there's it's not
coming from me the knock on is he's you
know he can kind of play it safe and uh
doesn't get finishes in title fights but
listen you're fighting the best of the
best man there's no knock on you you do
what you got to do you know so i'm not
part of that um
chatter when it comes izzy again i think
he's the best we have to offer and when
you talk about alex pierre you know and
that that's the whole narrative here and
izzy's always referring to him um
you know the only fight on this
main card that isn't perfect for the
champ as far as style wise is alexander
volkowski and max holloway
phenomenal [ __ ] fight yeah phenomenal
fight um
[Music]
when you look at uh pedro munoz sean
o'malley again
it's a big step up in competition for
sean o'malley who i do think it's time i
love what they've done with him and
slowed play it and let him get
experience and come off the dana white
contender series and he's building his
name outside the octagon and he's one of
the biggest stars um he has a new
contract i know he's getting paid also
our boy patty just signed a new contract
he's also getting paid so ufc is
starting to pay these big names because
the issue they're having now is guys
like sean o'malley and patty pimlet
they don't have to fight they're making
so much goddamn money outside the
octagon the ufc doesn't have a lot of
power over them anymore it's fantastic
again you got to be a you got to be an
outlier you'll be a unicorn like sean
o'malley or paddy pimlet in order to
make this type of money but god bless
them they have this option where they
don't when the ufc goes jump they'll no
i'm not jumping august 7th
no i'm good man i make too much money
doing other things they go okay we'll
jump october 5th
let me check my schedule
first time in the history of fighting we
have guys like this so it's fantastic so
for sean o'malley
who's finally i don't say finally but
you know he's a guy you you guys want to
see fight
oh my god dominic cruz and you know we
want to see the cody garbrandt fight i
definitely did before cody lost his last
one and you know the big knock on him if
you're uh a hater on sugar sean and he
has them but he also has a lot more fans
than haters but with sugar shawn is oh
he's not fighting top 10 guys well he's
not getting paid like top 10 guys so now
he's there
and you know pedro munoz
is a guy where they got pager at right
now they him at 10. sorry he's the top
10 guys sean's at 13. so um
you know this is a fight for sean
o'malley where his management whoever's
just handling his career
they they should be so overwhelmed by
applications from other ufc fighters
they've been so smart about it they've
built his career perfectly
darren tales should be applying to this
from day one there's certain fighters
that should be applying to work with
sugar shawn's management non-stop
he should they he should have
a hundred emails every morning when he
wakes up i don't know whose managers
everyone just wake up because the way
that they've handled sugar shawn's
career has never been done before i'm
sure they take heat for it i'm sure the
ufc you know tries to blackball them and
this whoever it is is just doing the
goddamn thing and they're doing it
flawlessly flawlessly because you know
for sugar shawn finally they pay him and
the uc see all right man it's time to
get going now and then they go okay well
you want to fight someone in the top 10
who's the best style
listicly matchup for us
well pedro munoz a pretty goddamn near
perfect style matchup free for a guy in
top 10. pedro munoz is a guy who
you know
grappling you know
[ __ ] you go back to the rankings as far
as you come straight jiu jitsu with
pedro munoz
by far the best jujitsu in the top 10 by
far you're talking about a guy who had
uh what over probably 700 jiu jitsu
matches uh former two-time world
champion so
world absolute world-class on the ground
comes jiu jitsu um so you know those are
feathers in
sugar shawn's hat if you can get past
guy like um you know pedro munoz
again stylistically pedro munoz not
known for his footwork not known for his
striking does have big power
um not really known for his
wrestling so
for sugar shawn a guy with his footwork
his range
it's a perfect stylistic fight for him
for his first time fighting a big dog in
the top ten it's a you could have picked
a better fight perfect perfect fight not
being said it's his toughest fight i'm
just saying i'm not saying to walk in
the park for sugar shawn but if you only
get the top 10 and go where's our how's
our best way to get to the top ten to
beat against top ten you lose that
entire list pedro munoz
not great footwork shorter
not you know not a striker
not really a phenomenal wrestler it has
the jiu jitsu wrestling which you know
is is easier to navigate if you're sugar
shan uh sugar shan's reach and again
footwork and quickness is gonna be the
differences thing you can stay you know
on the outside and light them up and
lead and frustrate uh pedro munoz and uh
hopefully get the finish now here's the
thing again
his management
who's dealing with sugar shawn is so
brilliant because
pedro meteos has never been finished so
if she shot where to get a finish that's
huge
but it's also
three round fight
main card huge ufc pay-per-view which
nothing new to show you sean
it allows him to showcase his talents
against a top 10 guy he's going to
release
the kraken on him as far as his striking
goes on the jab mixing it up southpaw
traditional it's going to be a long
night for pedro munoz unless pedro
can get them down early and wear them
out
that's a lot easier said than done
people want to again people want to
knock on sugar shawn's you know
wrestling and grappling abilities the
duke can [ __ ]
is just as good man he's not gonna be a
fish out of water if it does go on the
ground but
if you are pedro munoz fan and he gets
sugar shawn down early
you're gonna be rock hard because that's
his best way to get it done um i think
that's easier said than done for pedro
munoz i think it's a long night in the
office for him and that's saying a lot
picture me is fantastic fantastic but
stylistically there could not be a
better matchup
than pedro munoz for sugar shot it's
ideal
same thing goes for uh uh pierre for for
our boy alex pierra you know him not
really being ranked that high
and to get a guy in sean strickling
clearly sean strickland is going to
fight anybody they throw him and it's
you know very clear here because he's
fighting a guy on ranked
and he's ranked number four there's
really no business um or reasoning why
this fight's going on besides to get
pierra to title shot against izzy
because izzy needs fresh meat that's the
only thing going on here
now if you're pierra and you're his
management there couldn't be a better
matchup
in the top
15
than sean strickland because sean
strickland fancy himself a striker he
does not have the background of pierra
but he is i would say tougher than
pierre obviously has uh
the the experience in the ufc on his
side obviously has big fight energy on
his side so um
this fight to me is predicated off sean
strickland's ego
is his fight ego gonna win or is
you know the the dog in him who wants to
you know fancy himself a striker and try
to get done against honestly by far the
best striker in the middleweight
division um as far as straight
kickboxing goes i do not think he's a
better mma striker than izzy i don't i i
know his background he beat izzy cool
when it comes to mma i think izzy's more
creative and has more tools to get it
done against top tier guys
we'll see i could be wrong but as of now
i'm dead on so i do think uh for sean
strickling this is a matter of him
fighting smart not fighting with his
heart in his fight with his brain
because if you're just gonna
strike with this pierre guy it's gonna
be a highlight reel knockout for him and
you know sean strickland's as tough as
they come and he's beat some good guys
and you know as far as mentally goes
there's nobody tougher than this [ __ ]
guy but
you know when you're talking about a
world-class striker in oxfaire that's
what he wants man so i'm hoping with
sean strickland training with the
bellator champion with wrestling
grappling he's gonna
at least
attempt takedowns so pierre just can't
walk forward and tee off that's what you
got to hope for
but you only get like his [ __ ] record
he's doing work man he's doing work
but uh you know strickland does love to
strike and they what they say is
in in training camp uh in sparring it
really he just spars man he just goes
he's in the torso down he just goes he
goes man and you better bring your
mouthpiece when you're sparring him this
dude goes
so
again if you are a pierre fan there
couldn't be a better guy in the top 15
for him to showcase his talents against
than sean strickland if sean strickland
is trying to please the ufc and wants us
to have a stand-up war
it's tough man sean strickland needs to
make this thing dirty incorporate some
grappling make it a phone booth fight
make it get dirty sean and he knows this
he's a smart [ __ ] dude he knows this
but again if his ego goes i can knock
out this world-class striker
man you're messing with fire you're
messing with fire
i think by far the best fight on the
card they're all [ __ ] great on the
main card they're all great i'm into all
of them it's very rare i'm into all of
them some of them like come on can we
just want to get over to get to the next
fight
all four of these dude take my money any
one of these could be a main event and
you i pay for it uh but i do think the
most competitive best card on the best
fight on the card is volkanovsky max
hallway three
by far you know we had volkanovsky on
food truck and i said you know
obviously i'm biased and what's tough
now is now i mean me volkonovsky boys
i love max holloway he's one of my
favorite people on the goddamn planet
he's such a good person
um i love how good of a daddy is and
just you know y'all must have forgot
because
i think is maybe because max holloway
you know you saw him lose that dustin
poured fish or something like that at
featherweight that dude is damn near
impossible to beat
unless your name's alexander volkonovsky
yang beating him his last loss besides
alexander volkonowski was to ready conor
mcgregor
that's a hot second ago at 45
hot second ago dude so for max holloway
you know he is a featherweight king um
so i'm saying over a longer period of
time i'll say alexander volkanovski's
the champion so for alexander
volkonovsky when he was on food truck i
was telling him i just feel like for him
to get the credit that he deserves
whether he cares or not i don't know but
in order for him to get the credit in
america you have to convincingly beat
max holloway you have to close that
chapter this is how they close the
chapter this is exactly how they do it
unless max wins then when you get a
fourth fight again take my money because
i'll watch them fight every [ __ ]
saturday
um
you know a lot of experts and uh
former
fighters who are now analysts will say
max holloway needs the the perfect
performance like he had against cater or
you know or against ortega
you know yeah no [ __ ] dude oh you mean
to become the featherweight champion of
the world he has to have a good
performance he knew [ __ ] it's very rare
max doesn't have a great performance
again there seems to be you all must
have forgot how [ __ ] good the blessed
one is man um
but i i you know
alexander volkanovski is getting better
now if you're going based off their last
few fights especially their last fight
with alex volkonovsky fighting korean
zombie it's tough to tell where he's at
obviously he looked phenomenal in that
goddamn fight phenomenal
amazing now is that a case of vulkanasi
improving or is korean zombie getting
old and has one fight left him to retire
you know took destroy and they took to
find short notice the brian ortega fight
uh
he showed you that he's a guy you can
count on he's a guy who got in trouble
he's a guy who uh
i think 99 of the roster would submit to
that guillotine choke brian ortega hat
in and he was willing to go out and
somehow he got out of it and went on to
win that fight um so i think that really
built volkanovsky's career that you can
you can count on you can count him as a
champion so
um if you're gonna tell me who has had
better performances in their last two
fights after the last time they fought
in 2020
i would say i've seen more improvement
over max holloway that's not a knock on
volkanosi i'm just saying if you like
max holloway what he did in the yaya
rodriguez fight within the calvin kater
fight
not bad
not bad you can't tell me he hasn't
gotten better at his age dude and again
at featherweight max is damn near
impossible to beat damn near impossible
alexander volkonowski has to have a
flawless performance again both of these
[ __ ] show up so to say oh max
has to have a flawless performance no
[ __ ]
to beat volkanovsky you better have a
flawless
performance it's very rare maxwell he
didn't show up if you look at the i
don't think he's never not shown up even
though that doesn't parry fight he's
just too small he showed the [ __ ] up the
two volkanovsky fights shut the [ __ ] up
i had him win that second one lost the
first one i'll give you that i thought
he won segwit doesn't matter but there's
a reason why he's on two and they'll
give him another [ __ ] title shot
there's a reason
you know so um i think this is by far
the most competitive fight on the card
um this fight to me is just
who is the featherweight king who is the
pound-for-pound featherweight king
volcano max holloway we're going to
finance saturday
hard for me to not cheer for max
holloway also hard for me not to cheer
for a volcano i love [ __ ] both of
them okanasi was such a fun food truck
we shared whiskey he's just a good dude
family dude he wanted to get back home
because he missed his kids like oh
great dude
the max hallway just made that dime
piece here's his son
doing the goddamn thing but you almost
forgot about max all that featherweight
dude he is damn near the best we've ever
had
yeah i would say probably is you look at
his the history of what he's done at
featherweight
the whole card is fantastic
but uh if i have to give picks i would
take izzy i do think it's the tougher
fight that most people think
there was a bigger gap between
uh
anderson silva and forrest griffin then
there is izzy and jared kennedy cannon
air is a [ __ ] dog big powerful
the speed is gonna be the problem there
for for jared now is jared watching the
the yawn fight and going all right this
is how you do it maybe that's
way easier said than done at 85.
i think for izzy you know
if pierra has like some crazy you know
flying knee knockout obviously that
builds that fight tremendously um
but if pierre were to lose i get you'd
probably give sean street because here's
the thing
and sean strickland at four if sean
strickland beats alex pierre is he
guaranteed a title shot
no because we know
100 percent if alex beats sean
strickland he's going title shot there's
no
ands if butts about it that's happening
for a fact there's no that's the only
reason he's
not ranked fighting number four guy they
want to get that going
so you know for izzy again there's a
reason why alex pierre not ranked only
is what third fourth fight new seas
fighting sean strickland they need fresh
meat for izzy so for izzy it's a bit of
if alex wins clary fight alex or you
find sean strickland okay stylishly
great matches frazee again he'd be
favored in both those fights so there's
not a lot of metal weight for him
i do think
uh light heavyweight is the is izzy's
next accomplishment
and especially now that yawn's out of
the picture
out of the picture being not champ
you know
the the the match-up form up there is so
much better so much better so
i do think that's his future
i think it's just a matter of time he's
gonna go back up 205 the yawn experiment
was just a nightmare so i i do think
with these other light
heavyweights there's definitely a fun
matchup for izzy you know and there
they'd be striking wars not a guy who's
going to lay and prey on him the bigger
guy probably walking at 240 and just
going to lay on him i think izzy at 205
depending who's the champion can
definitely be your light heavyweight
champion i really do and when he's on
food truck you see he goes man i'm
telling you people keep thinking i'm
small i'm not smalling you not at all
you're bringing the meat dude i found a
heavyweight [ __ ]
i yes he's a freak man
um izzy's a freak and also
obviously khabib was their biggest
international star but i would say is
he's the biggest star
internationally you know i think
pay-per-view wise obviously conor is
still but as far as active current tip
of the spare champions is he's your
biggest star
the guy checks all [ __ ] boxes
he does his youtube channel blows the
[ __ ] up like anything he touches he
crosses over too he's into anime and
[ __ ] he's on talking [ __ ] on social
media i think playing video games and
[ __ ] tries to make laird even though he
doesn't know cars
i told him how to race him if he ever
came out here
so that's cool
um but i can't i can't wait for this ufc
276. and then also
i know they're looking for a replace for
mr tate
hey hey ufc do me a favor show a little
respect either put robbie lawler versus
brian barbarina on the opening main card
bout or how about you put
jim miller donald cerrone on there we
don't need jim miller don cerrone open
up the prelims
that is offensive
i know it's abc
who gives a [ __ ]
put those guys on the main card and
pay-per-view
you tell me jim miller donald truoney to
open up pay for you want to get
everybody's dick card
or robbie i'll tell you right now robbie
lawler brian barbaria that thing ain't
going decision and if it does you gotta
fight the night so either way you're
gonna dope ass knockout you're gonna
fight a knight you put that on the main
card
brad riddle and uh turner's fantastic
fight too you could easily put that have
them open that up
easily
ian gary i mean god damn yeah you're
right hall on there just guy brad
tavares just dude jessica rose clark i
mean pick any of them too
pick any of them for god's sakes but
just for just for out of sheer respect
if you don't add ra robbie lawler or
donald trump the main card
that's rude it's just rude man
i hope they figure it out
the robbie barbarino one that's the oh
for sure
that's a fun [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
jim miller's cerrone is fun too
true by steve
two-two hall-of-famers
yeah favorite in that robbie lawler
brian barino one chin
robbie lawler is the slight he's a
favorite is he uh i kind of feel like
brian will take it
brian will the only thing with this is
agree so
uh i'm going to do my draftkings picks
uh
and it's i love uh robbie lawler
absolutely love him legend of the sport
um
but you know as far if you want to make
money when i when i pick my my draftking
bets i want you guys to make money
it's not a bad idea to put some money on
brian barbarina because it's basically a
pickum
in minus 125 you have to put 100 you
know 125 out to make 100. with brian
barbarina it's even money and without
fight
brian barbarina does get hit but robbie
lawler is a slow starter brian's a
monster in that first round i could see
brian winning the first round i'm
putting money on it i'm telling you guys
put money on
you know
yeah look dude sean strickland alex
pierre minus 115 minus 105.
volkanovsky minus 190 max hallway plus
160.
interesting and then is the biggest
favorite on the card minus 365.
oh
i can't wait for this for the card can
we do a companion it's gonna be so much
fun man let's take a little break before
we uh have my boy josh emmett on he's
gonna break down the ufc 276
big matchups for you guys but hopefully
you guys get enough sleep man because i
know you're cranky right now inflation's
popping you guys are stressed out about
politics or sports whatever it is man
and one of the reasons i can get sleep
because your mattress sucks yeah your
mattress really sucks because you don't
have a helix sleep mattress that's what
i have in my crib that's what i sleep on
all my guest rooms have it i can't get
rid of my in-laws i can't get rid of my
friends it's not because they like me
it's because they love these mattresses
helix sleep mattress it's not a mattress
for just anybody man it's the mattress
made just for you yep my friends at
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress just for you all right
whatever you like side sleeper stomach
sleeper you sleep hot cold you want firm
soft whatever it is we got the exact
mattress for your thick ass you don't
need to take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress in 2019 and 2020 by gq and
wired magazine all right
wired magazine
again i have them all my house i sleep
by every night i sleep a goddamn baby
all right just go to helixleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz you'll
get a customized mattress that will give
you your best sleep ever they have a
10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free they'll even
pick it up if you don't love it but you
also don't worry about that helix sleep
is offering up to 200 dollars off all
mattress orders and free pillows for all
the listeners and viewers of the shop
show helixsleep.com
that's helix sleep.com for up to 200 off
ufc 276 is here kids and you can watch
it you can watch the cowboys fight
command 7pm pacific live on the thinkboy
youtube you can watch all that you watch
the main pay-per-view you watch my
cowboys fight companion and you can also
make money with my friends at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the ufc new customers can bet
five dollars on any fighter to win and
get 100 in free bets win or lose whether
it's izzy with a knockout kick or
powerful punch or cannon air gets it
done by decision you win no matter what
and with draftkings same game parlays
you can turn another small bet into big
payday combine multiple bets like which
fighter will win number of knockouts and
more for ufc 276 you can place the same
game parlay if it hits you win double
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code shobb s-h-a-b bet 5
on any ufc 276 fighter to win you get
100 in free bets no matter what that's
coach schaub this saturday at draftking
sportsbook the official sportswearing
partner the ufc minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details draftkings
all right jim what do you got
we got josh edmond on the phone yeah we
got josh emmett oh my god
let's do it
let's do it mr josh emmett the number
four man in the world how's that how's
that feel how's that how's that sound to
you being ranked number four now ah man
it doesn't
i guess it seems all right you know i
always feel like the the numbers i don't
really care too much about rankings just
because i feel like that
i feel like the ufc manipulates those
numbers based off of who they want to
fight sure um
but it is it is what it is it's getting
me closer and closer to that uh that
title shot and i feel like i feel like
i'm next regardless of the outcome on
july 2nd i feel like i get the winner
yeah i agree though yeah the only reason
if i was still fighting i'd care about
the rankings is because
it just gives you kind of a blueprint on
how close you are to the title shot but
to the you know the opposite of that
sometimes it doesn't sometimes you know
sometimes a guy who's not ranked or a
guy who hasn't been fighting will just
jump in there and get a total shot but
for a guy like you who's been
really earning his way you know more
more so than most people to get that
title shot man you are right there so
when i saw they ranked you number four
it's like oh [ __ ] yeah we're we're
getting close man we're getting freaking
close
yeah and that's what i i assumed i would
uh i would take you know caters caterers
ranking he was ranked number four so i
felt at least i would be four um but i
still feel like that was a title
eliminator fight i feel like it was uh
the number one contender spot and so
that's why i'm just gunning for this uh
this title shot so bad you know i feel
like i've been putting in the work for
so long and you know i i feel like i've
i've earned it
i couldn't agree more you you've earned
it more so than anybody i think too
you know cater's my boy we had caterer
on the week when you guys fought i i you
know cater is a buddy of mine and so i'm
a little biased and you and i haven't
spoke so hopefully you don't get mad at
me but you know i was rooting for a
caterer and
i was uh i was on stage so i missed your
guys main event but i recorded it and
um i had you know my buddies text me
about the fight and stuff like that and
because i am a bias uh you know
personality in the spot if i'm close to
somebody uh my before i watch the fight
i went and i've always been a fan of
yours you're a monster but i was like
all right my plan is to come in i always
want to come up with some sort of
narrative like a storyline on monday
mornings i was like right i'm gonna
watch the fight and because it was such
a close fight i bet i can
spin it and argue for cater that was
when i knew you won already that was my
plan and i sat down i had my notepad i'm
like right let's see what we can do for
cater here and i watch them like
i can do nothing cater did not win this
fight you know it was just you know you
just you did your thing man it was so
goddamn impressive and you know more so
than anybody cater is an absolute
monster man he's an absolute savage out
there but you just did the goddamn thing
man
yeah and that's what it you know i give
my opponents uh the utmost respect
before fights because i watch a lot of i
watch a lot of film on them and uh and
cater is a dog like i knew i was going
to be in for a hell of a fight um look
at look at the guys he's fought look at
the guys he's beat um and his
performances you know he he's he kind of
reminds me of like you know like
holloway and volkanovsky how like those
guys they continue to get better and
better like he took a year off he came
back and had an amazing performance
against giga um that a lot of people
were counting him out against but i
actually i was like cater is gonna shut
down that kickboxing he's gonna pressure
him use his his boxing and and he did
just that and implemented some wrestling
and he looked good on the ground as far
as jiu jitsu as well but
um
yeah when i got in there i just
you know it's different i want to get
hit by someone i want to get hit by them
i want to see how hard they hit i want
to feel like see how fast they are i
want to like tie up in the clinch and
see how strong they are so it's like i
give them this respect but
once i got in there
you know it i didn't really see anything
that i i wasn't expecting and i spar
with some of the top guys in the world i
even boxing i i've been boxing and
sparring some of my friends that are pro
boxers and they're they're really good
and so it's like punches and bunches
those guys hit
they they hit much harder you know and
the punches do not stop it's like we're
supporting the volume yeah the volume is
insane it's like we're sparring three
minute rounds but that entire three
minutes is just punches after punches
and they're hard shots so
i knew i was prepared um
and i can box man if we throw on some
boxing gloves and you watch me go to a
boxing gym and spar these
i can shell up and i can sit in the
pocket and slip and roll and you know go
to work but mma is different so
i know like boxing in mma is it's a
little different but uh for sure you
know once i once i got in there i you
know i felt i felt his power um
he wasn't as fast as i thought he was
you know um
and the thing with my boxing coach joey
he's still
he gets pissed just because like he's
like move your [ __ ] head even though
i was even though i was like man the
powers
it's i just felt like he didn't have as
much power as i thought he was gonna
have yeah so he was still telling me
move your [ __ ] head like don't get
hit with that when i was moving and just
like
keeping good head movement then i was
making him miss but
um
you know he's he's a good dude i knew
going in there i was going gonna be in a
hell of a fight um afterwards you know i
i have nothing but respect for cater his
coaches his teammates
um and he is a he's a really good guy
too you know he had some some nice
things to say after the fight and uh
yeah like i wish him nothing but the
best in his uh his career yeah you're
both
good guys you're both good guys and you
know you don't do the kind of wwe [ __ ]
talk thing which you know
i i enjoy i think you know you guys
talents speak for themselves and that's
also why you know your road to the title
shot has come just through hard work and
beating the best guys in the world
you know but when you look at the
division you know you got ortega yaya
rodriguez
you know that there could be an argument
there where the winner of that
especially if jair to win that i don't
think he does but if i were to win that
he would get a title shot you know so
uh
i guess
there's nobody better
that is in this room uh to to kind of
give us picks on your rodriguez brian
ortega and volkanovsky and max holloway
were you at on those
yeah it's uh
even with volkanoski and holloway i i
feel like
both great fighters uh you know max was
arguably one of the best featherweights
of all time but it's hard for me to go
against volkanoski he's he's on a
20-plus fight winning streak the guy is
undefeated in the ufc he's beat some of
the the legends and the all-time greats
and he continues to get better and
better with each showing
so i'm kind of leaning towards him you
know
and then as far as ortega and yair again
great fighters it's it's more of a you
know the the old-school
uh
striker versus grappler but ortega you
know he's he's a big featherweight too
he's got some power he can crack
um
you know and it's like his wrestling's
getting better everything so it's like i
hate i i really hate picking
fights
i can argue how how both guys win like i
can argue how yeah here gets the job
done
ortega gets the job done but i think at
the end of the day
um
i don't know i'm kind of leaning towards
ortega as well he's super durable um i
feel like he has some of the best
grappling in not even just the
featherweight division i feel like in
the entire ufc you know his jiu-jitsu um
so i feel like if he can get his hands
on him or wrap his arms around his neck
or you know if he were to rock yeah and
he shoots then it's like
but who the hell knows you know we'll
find out who wants the bell uh that's
the thing picking fights in mma i i
talked to this pro betting guy and he
goes uh he goes to be honest with you
the only sport i don't uh bet on is mma
yeah
he goes your odds of coming out on top
or having you know a successful betting
career uh in mma is the worst i have any
professional sport he was just too many
variables he's like you never know
there's too many ways to lose something
could happen the weight cut he's like i
don't like putting my money on mma it's
too tough to pick and when i heard that
from actually i'm like oh jesus christ
hey that makes me feel better if i do
pick and i'm always wrong but it's just
it's a tough sport to bet on man because
you never know what's going on
but going back to ortega yair
would argue it's better for you if
ortega wins
yep
you know no i i agree and it's the same
thing so i'm like okay
i never want to
you know i don't wish anyone to lose
because we're all trying to accomplish
the same thing um but
for
me being um i guess selfish and just
wanting it to like gotta be yeah i feel
like i and i do that within my training
and when i like you know isolate myself
from my my friends and family but it's
like i would say volkanovsky wins and
ortega wins like then there's no other
fight to make but
myself and volkanovsky um
but but then again i feel like either
one of those guys that win then they're
on a one-fight winning streak and i know
with the ufc they they keep the guys
they just stick them there and they stay
there whether they're inactive for a
year two years they come off one when
they're they're right there in the top
three they don't move them
and and so that's the thing i i feel
like we've seen these fights already i'm
the only one that has not fought for the
title and
and i feel like i said i i earned it you
know no one deserves [ __ ] in life but i
earned this and uh
that's man that's the fight to make and
stylistically volkanovsky and i match up
so similar he's a great champion he
seems like a good dude and uh for once i
would actually have the height advantage
not by much but it would be nice to
actually be the
for once in my career
that's hilarious yeah i think you know
knowing what you've accomplished stuff
like that i would assume
you would want volkanovsky to beat max
holloway just because
it's volkanovsky you know he's the king
of division and if you become champ you
want to take out the the top dog
so for you to take out a guy like
volkowski you know there's there's
there's nothing bigger so if volkanovsky
were to get past you know the fight this
saturday you know and you get that fight
that's probably the fight if i'm you and
i'm in your camp we're we i mean max
hallway is a big name no matter what
matt said
the only again the only thing if again
if i'm in your camp i'm not saying
you're doing this but if i'm in your
camp i'm rooting for a volcano because
max wins let's say it's another close
decision
you know even though he's owen two he
wins this one the ufc is going to want
to run it back maybe depending you know
so just
it ties you up longer so if volkanovsky
can win
the max hallway volcanosi story is over
you know if he's on three it's it's just
give me a tough picture to paint again
for the fourth time yeah i feel like it
solidifies that and then and then
volcano like he said he's
he's one of the pound-for-pound best too
so in my eyes like i really want to
fight the best because i always rise to
the occasion they always bring out the
best in me and then i can show people
how good i am you know um you know i
still got all these these naysayers and
things like that but i i love being the
underdog um and and i love proven people
that don't know me wrong
yeah i don't know yeah those naysayers i
don't know how long they're gonna stick
around when you look at your record and
just over the your entire career it's
not like you're some
you know newbie like
you know if i you know i'm i'm big on
paddy pimlet or or sugarshawn o'malley
and i'll have people arguing about them
that's fine i get that they haven't you
know
had the career you've had in the ufc so
i'm like no i can see how you say that
but i still defend them with you there's
not much to go on it's pretty [ __ ]
evident dude like clearly the guy has
worked his [ __ ] tail off got won the
big fights beat some of the best in the
division you're on this crazy win streak
so there's not really a narrative there
to say oh he hasn't earned it or he
shouldn't be in the top five it's like i
i listen
around and i you know i have my share of
haters around the water coolers i'm
around nobody's saying this dude
everyone's like yeah emmett's the next
guy man well yeah i agree i appreciate
it
and uh how how how do you think your
life would change you became champ i
mean i'm i'm assuming that's your house
unless you're on some stage right now i
assume that your crib
i mean pretty nice crib you got your you
uh married you got your girl right yep
kiddos
no no kids we're we're like
we're the only ones out of all of our
friends that don't have kids yet um we
have god children we have nephews it's
uh
it's just tough that was always the plan
like six years ago and then it's like
now we finally once i got in the ufc and
we can actually do things that we always
kind of dreamed of um we like really
love our life um
we like our freedom yeah but we're also
like you know we have that discussion
like non-stop all the time and we're
like we know in the next year or so we
we don't want children but we also don't
want to get to the point where we have
any regrets you know what i mean um so
it's a
yeah it's a yeah it's it's a fine line
you're talking about a father of two and
don't get around to the beast but i've
done a lot of cool [ __ ] my life man
nothing's better than being a dad dude
and my argument for you is you're a good
person you know we need more josh
emmett's in the world so that's why you
should have kids
yeah and that's and trust me like we're
getting it from everyone and we're just
like
we love to travel we wanted you know all
of our friends and stuff that have you
know kids are just like enjoy your time
like go travel first get that out of the
way but it's like
yeah we regardless we're gonna be happy
regardless but it's yeah you'll be all
right you don't be the seth seth rogan
of mma you know what i'm saying he's
just like smoking weed and traveling all
the time because take it from a guy who
travels non-stop as a comic after a
while all the hotels look the same i
could be doing shows in ukraine or
freaking dubai i have no clue every city
looks the same man okay yeah yeah but
yeah it was going back to your question
it would change your life and i knew
this this win over um cater would kind
of start the process um and we're just
doing so much so it's like
the better you know obviously i do my
career the better my my family and
friends and every every business i'm a
part of does um and
we're in the process right now we're
building a
you know a place in our backyard for my
mom um
like two months ago and then we
i got the biggest fight we were dealing
with permanent since september we were
doing all our like inspections and all
these other things and i have you know
one of my good friend
brandon one of my best friends he's
being the gc of the project right now
and he's helping like you know line
everything up and all the subs so it's
been a chaotic uh
few months but it's like yeah all that
will pay off and becoming the champion
he'll just be able to
get out of debt pay everything off and
then
start you know i
i don't need anything like flashy i know
what i want you know so it's just like
i'm you'll never catch me buying like
crazy expensive cars or
um like clothes i just want to you know
take care of my my friends and family
and uh yeah just enjoy the experiences
and life and yeah just just have a good
time you know invest my money wisely
that's for sure yeah no you seem like a
smart dude i love that man yeah and for
the viewers and out there who don't know
is josh lives in uh sacramento so um to
get a permit in california do anything
is a nightmare it takes forever dude
forever september we were doing this um
and then we finally we finally got our
permits i i want to say like
i don't know you know maybe a month and
a half ago and then like the very next
day we started demo you know and that's
that's fast though
like bill maher was talking about he
wanted uh solar panels and to get like
the permanent stuff he's waited years to
some people wait years yeah this wall
thing i've been dealing with for four
years and we're even doing with like
you're talking about solar it's like
even in california it's like every unit
needs some
salt so we had to get a solar report and
do this others you know hire the honey
we went through loophole like tons of
loops just to get all this stuff kind of
situated but at least with it taking
some time we just got another quote on
lumber this morning so i i know the
lumber price has gone down a little bit
so yeah that's that's awesome
um
but it's damn it's this is pricey it's a
beast yeah the the the fight you're
fighting with these permits and stuff to
build this thing for your for your mom
is probably going to be tougher than
your fight against volkanovsky my man
for sure it's a different animal yeah i
love it mentally
yeah i'll get you out of here on this
how how
how important has it been to to uh train
at uh you know team alpha male with your
eye of favor you know i love uriah
you're as a good buddy uh
how has that been for you because team
alpha male you know you guys
if you think about team alpha man the
the kind of the evolution of team alpha
male you know
i don't know how many years ago team
alpha male was especially when you're i
was fighting a tj there at cody you were
that you just have these monsters and
then until now like
is it weird for you to be the biggest
name out of team alpha man when you
think about all the legendary fighters
that come out of there
yeah it's crazy i i'm super grateful for
uriah just i'm from sacramento so i'm
grateful he opened one of the best teams
for the lighter weights in the world in
my backyard
i really don't think i'll be fighting if
uh if he didn't do that just because i i
had no money like there was no way i
could have went like traveled somewhere
um
to pursue this this dream of mine that
took over a decade to get in the ufc
um so i really don't think i'll be
fighting if he didn't open this gym um
but but i also i was there since the
beginning like in 2005 when he opened it
um i was in there like i was training i
was the main training partner for
you know my my coach now danny castillo
when he was making his ufc debut against
joe daddy stevenson
tj's uh you know training partners
uriah's chad mendes when he was fighting
jose aldo and this is when i was like
1-0 as an amateur you know so i kind of
knew where i
i stacked up this whole time and we've
had people from all over the world come
in to to train with us and i would go
with them
um and even back in the day i think when
i was a professional one or two and oh i
told uriah i only wanted to fight in the
ufc
nothing else and he's like it's going to
take some while it's going to take some
time to do that but he says you're one
of the best fighters in the world just
nobody knows it yet and that was like
that was over a decade ago
so he was right
like and so it kind of went over my head
i was like yeah what's this yeah right
you know but then i look back at it now
and i'm like he has an eye for talent
like he recruited
all these guys and um
he saw potential in me and look look at
the people like benavidez dillashaw
mendez last call like
and the list goes on and on like
and they're all great fighters i wish
them all the best i've learned from
every single one of them
yeah so it's it's cool to look back and
and him say that to me and then now i'm
like where i'm at i'm like damn he this
guy
it's like he has a crystal ball or
something
yeah your eye is like the p diddy for
mma man he just puts people on and he's
such a business savvy dude i love your
iron man well and it must be special
that you know you're the the top dog
there now man everyone's talking about
you and you've
again i think one of the reasons why i
just dig your whole story is you've
you've you haven't been given anything
you know it's not these hot promos or
this weird kind of you know press stuff
you're doing or talking [ __ ] on social
media like you you just you went about
the the long road and you've earned it
man and we're rooting for you here and
you know hopefully uh you know saturday
makes things a little clearer for you
and i i i pray to god you get the next
title shot man i really do i hope that
works out for you man cool thank you so
much yeah i appreciate you brother
thanks for coming on man yeah it's great
to be here and then yeah let me know uh
i want to hop on that food truck diaries
let's do it brother let's do it let me
know do you know around what uh time
you're coming down here no i'm not sure
i i know i was talking to your producer
and uh
i was just trying to map it out whenever
we head down there or vice versa
if it's up to us i can [ __ ] when we get
off my producers right here we'll talk
right now we'll make it happen man yeah
i'm down whenever man i'm i'm all about
the good food and uh i feel like that's
where all our money goes is good food
and uh
and travel 100 100 dude
most of the overhead on think boys from
these goddamn food trucks so we're doing
it i can get up there too i
gaining weight is no issue for me losing
the weights a little challenging but i
could pack on the pounds i hear your
brother i hear the exact same problem
well we got good food trucks out in l.a
man so we'll make it happen and uh
hopefully we're talking about announcing
your freaking you know title shot that's
the plan dude so wish you the best
brother keep working your ass off you
got a fan here man thanks for coming on
thank you have a good one hi brother
take care let's take another little
break about talking about fights because
i need a little ad for you here last one
kids because ufc 276 is here you can
watch it on the pay-per-view you can
watch the cowboys fight companion at 7
p.m pacific on the thick boy youtube
with me and my squad whatever you want
to do you're going to watch it you can
make bank with my friends at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports brand
partner the ufc new customers can bet
five dollars on any fighter to win and
get 100 in free bets win or lose whether
it's izzy with a sick knockout or cannon
air gets done via decision you win no
matter what and with draftkings same
game parlays you can turn another small
bet into big payday you can bet on my
boosted uh parlay and my fighters for
this ufc 276 are izzy
sugar sean and brian barbarina if you
pick those three they all three have to
win brian is the only slight dog in that
but if you pick all three of them to win
you're gonna get even more money dude
that's how it works all right
combine multiple bets like which fighter
will win number of knockouts and more
for ufc 276 you can play the same game
parlay if it hits you win double like my
freaking parlay with the three fighters
i just mentioned izzy suga brian get it
done click on the shob uh pics you click
on it it will boost your odds
automatically download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use prom code
shobb s-c-h-a-b you bet five dollars on
any ufc 276 fighter to win you get one
hundred dollars in free bets no matter
what that's coach schaub this saturday
at draftkings sportsbook the official
sportsman and partner of the ufc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
draftkings promo code shob
there you have it man mr josh emmett
dude has gone the long route to a
freaking title shot
again i think it's all predicated off of
you know if yaya rodriguez was
able to
get like a high highlight reel finish
over ortega they might give it to him
over emmett
um and then if max holloway were to win
i think they do an immediate
fourth fight between max and volkanovsky
so there's some x factors that i think
could delay emmick in this title shot
you know
because if brian ortega wins and then
let's say max wins i think they would do
uh
emmett vs ortega for the title
eliminator you know so there's some
some variables in there that he's
working against but he definitely
deserves it man hopefully he gets it
all right so the first one you you guys
covered this on the hot takes right as
far as uh
jake paul and tommy fury actually the
fights back on yeah it was off and now
it's back on august 6th that's square
garden yeah and well so there's a few
wrinkles there so i guess um tommy
fury's dad and tyson fury can't get into
the country so he's not gonna have them
in the corner okay um but anyways tyson
fury
wanted to bet a hundred thousand dollars
to jake paul hundred thousand and then
jake paul
i'll just play jake's paul's video to
you real quick
all right everyone wait for it so this
is what tyson fury just said in an
interview check it i'm backing tommy
i'll put my money where my mouth is got
100 grand with anybody i'll put it on
tommy and that's it that's how i feel
about it so guys tyson fury who made 40
million dollars last year is willing to
bet 100k on his brother oh my gosh we're
shaking hey tyson you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
made 40 million dollars i know it wasn't
as much as me but let's up the ante
let's bet a million on it tyson two
million three however much you wanna
[ __ ] bet let's do it are you down
make a deal see i could tell when
someone's really not confident because
these [ __ ] [ __ ] twitter and
the internet whoever's watching aaron
here they're all on this twitter app
they're scared i can tell when they're
scared but me i'm a cold [ __ ] i
bet anyone anytime any place let's run
it up so [ __ ] your 100k make this a
better bet and make it worth a couple
million are you down
i'm with them man when i heard 100k i'm
like oh they're clearly not uh too
confident in their boy
considering how much he's worth yeah
dude but here's how tyson responded
looking like it this is the message to
jake paul
hey jakey boy
i hear you want a better bigger bet than
a hundred thousand dollars you want a
bigger [ __ ] you want a million
dollars
you want a million you got it
you got it
i don't know how you talk like that
whatever they're both talking a little
bit yeah jake's shoes were fire those
off white dunks um yeah i mean 100 grand
it's like what are we doing here man uh
hold on scroll up what did jake say uh
hey jake i want to see his million
dollars in escrow sucker because i don't
think you've got a oh well
sorry but hey i hear you're a big event
uh you want a bigger bet mother trucker
you want a million dollars let's do it
hold out your boy you want a million you
got it and hey jakey i want to see this
million dollars in escrow sucker because
i don't think you've got a million
dollars
come on tyson uh i ain't talking about
crypto i'm talking about real us
greenbacks mother trucker real us
dollars no crypto yeah i'm with tyson
dude i don't want any of that [ __ ]
don't wish i could give you an ft crypto
deutsche coin or where the hell it is i
need to straight up million dollars in
escrow but of course he has a million
dollars tyson yeah
um we kind of talked about this a little
bit but so i guess mike tyson said that
he would want to box jake paul and jake
paul like we should make this happen
yeah by the end of this year yeah that's
what he said it's gonna happen so yeah i
don't for you know
i
i don't see what it does for jake you
know if you if you fight a you know
obviously there there's no
kind of
circus shows when you fight ben askren
when you're fighting freaking woodley
twice now you're fighting tommy fury
who's a quote-unquote real boxer
you know so to me the mike tyson like
give that to logan paul jake let logan
do that the thing make all the money for
jake i don't see how this
pushes his career in the right direction
if that makes sense big money play maybe
people will watch but as far as
getting the accolades and the the
credentials that you want and the the
confirmation from the fight fans this
ain't gonna do it i'm not too crazy
about it
yeah and i wonder how jake would do
against tyson too like i don't know
tyson's a lot older dude that's true
that's true but yeah and then also would
he be
going gonna go off of him versus
freaking roy jones which was
yeah there's a gentleman's bet not to
you know it was kind of a glorified
sparring match
if it's like that the hell no yeah
that's what i'm saying i i don't like it
for jake
all right um also conor mcgregor
employed me with her apparently people
are saying that they're talking to do a
rematch in boxing i don't i'm
you're out of it yeah i don't i don't
i don't want
no no no i don't want to see it because
you have to think about it the first one
here's the thing will it make money yes
of course we'll make the same money get
the same traction as the first one not
[ __ ] close you're talking about conor
mcgregor obviously my job on showtime
was to sell you guys on how conor can
win
you know we've seen the fight you know
it's a very tough fight for connor and
that was conor in his prime now he's
older coming off you know some surgeries
some you know issues with the law
i'm i'm all set man
and for floyd it's like he's fighting
sparring partners he's fighting guys
we've never heard him he's fighting
dubai he's fighting here and he
ah it's just these money grabs man in
inflation dude what are we doing
yeah i mean it's [ __ ] insane i'm i
don't want to see that [ __ ] i don't
know how excited i'd be dude connor has
such bigger fish on his plate like legit
fights that he needs to get done and get
back on the right path
this to me is another distraction right
it's another distraction bro you got
maybe a tony ferguson get a win and then
there's charles oliveira there's there's
all these other fights now
if when conor's 40 if you want to take
that fight when floyd's 70 or where the
[ __ ] is do that but
anytime the next three years connor you
got so much other [ __ ] you got to do
inside that ufc octagon forget floyd
mayweather man
i don't want to see that [ __ ] yeah
all right what do you think of this this
is tyson chartier this is caters coach
and this is what he thinks about uh this
is his like view of a new scoring system
that he thinks
429 likes uh so his new scoring system
he says each round winner determined by
judge's majority many at least two of
the three judges scored the round for
you majority winner of the round gets
one point loser gets zero
open scoring stall calls available with
possible point uh deduction uh dealer
fighters on scoring cards from coasting
at the end that's what pride did uh noma
system a truly close round can be
determined zero zero
uh winners determined by whichever
fighter gets more total points
uh i like if some of this stuff i like
my favorite thing is the uh the must
system so a no muss system a truly a
close round if it's so competitive
these judges don't have
the ability to decide exactly who's
gonna win i'm fine with a zero zero
round you know sometimes those rounds
are [ __ ] closer maybe some guy does
something
really
good and early in the round the end of
the round you know they get taken down
so you know there's some of these rounds
0-0 i'm i'm all for that but you know
uh the rest of it's tough
okay well i mean that is a good thing
the normal system i agree
you covered this a little bit on or a
lot on hot takes but so remember nate
diaz
uh i know so dana white was saying how
nate does only want a few five shade
yeah but he threw some shade but it's
also very black and white yeah
it is it's just like a numbers thing
it's like if roger goodell if people
were like why aren't the cowboys in the
super bowl he's like they've won like
one playoff game in like 15 years dude
what do you want me like yeah they're
the most popular but that's the way it
works
so i i to dana's credit i'm sure he's
getting a lot of [ __ ] online right i'm
sure people like hey man people keep
saying
you know when's nate diaz gonna fight
how come he's not fighting for the title
how come he's not fighting this guy at
the end of the day dan's like i get it
we are in the entertainment business but
same time he's won one fight in six
years like be cool man
we have to be careful how we match him
up because it's not like he's on a
six-fight winning streak that'd be much
easier to navigate these waters than
what he's doing now
yeah and again but again the nate diaz
fan bros are so passionate about him
which is great for nate
but at the same time too dana has to run
a business so
i mean should we just pretend he hasn't
won one fight in six years like how how
should dana handle that because those
are facts
that's that you know
sucks and i don't think he's throwing
shade but
dana didn't lose those fights you know
so here's i mean like nate let's be
honest nate's won one fight in the last
five or six years you know that when you
guys get into these positions guys that
have been with us for a long time that
we respect and we care about you got the
cerrone's anthony pettis before he left
nate diaz nick diaz is still under
contract with us you want to uh be fair
to everybody and do the right things
nate isn't going to fight kamar usman
listen we are trying to do the best we
can trying not to [ __ ] on anybody and
disrespect anybody it's not like we're
talking about kamar usman here we're
talking about nate diaz nate's won one
fight in five or six years so we're
trying to figure this thing out with him
he probably should go on and fight jake
paul that's fine that makes sense
i see i didn't take that as too much
shade i think that's him being honest
like hey you guys want to know why it's
taking so long he's won one fight in the
last six years man it it doesn't make
sense like we do we're still a
professional sports league we can't toss
nate diaz to kamar hussman it's not like
he's coming off a win
like what what narrative would or what
picture would that paint professional
sports would go this guy's really famous
though but he's going to fight the
greatest wealth away on the planet who's
won helmet in a row
it did you have seen a tough position
but the the rabid nick diaz fan base and
hds fanbase just doesn't they're
relentless yeah
so nate responded with this tweet i'll
just play the video at least i never a
lot really lost like all these [ __ ]
but here's
here's the
problem with posting
the video where he rocked leon edwards
with 30 seconds left
he lost that [ __ ] to dana's point he's
like
no that was a cool moment it was 50
seconds left in a five-round fight that
you completely lost
you know so it almost kind of helps
dana there he's like it starts with
you know
he's just showing how all the other guys
got finished but he's like he's not
finished yet it doesn't matter but then
also you post a video of charles
oliveira choking out justin gaichy
justin gates has won a ton of fights
you know yeah
who else is showing that
let's see here so this is
so it's michael chan like with chandler
you know again michael chandler's coming
off the you know mazda usman yeah
gusman you know
again all these guys connor dusty dustin
but but again all these guys are winning
now he's posting a a video of dustin
parry losing to michael chandler michael
johnson michael johnson seven years ago
and then him winning versus conor that's
the last one
you know
so this almost helps dana white you know
it's like there you go yeah yeah no
that's exactly what i'm trying
so i i just for both party dana just let
him go
all right if you have such tough time
match them up which really is just
buying time to
connor approves the fight
but just let him go
you know like let him go on like even he
said jake paul cool
so this is dan hardy um on nate's side
about just because of how disrespectful
he feels it was disrespectful you said
it wasn't that disrespectful
because it's true right yeah
if it wasn't true if he was like
let's say nate was on a five
five fight win streak and dave's like we
just can't find a fight no one felt like
what yeah he's one of the biggest names
he won five fights don't have to fight
your time i'll give him a title shot
damn but you know
again dana's not losing these flights
it's pretty black and white it's just
what it is unfortunately and i'm an ats
fan
so this is dan hardy who i love and
respect but this is the whole reason why
there's a class-action lawsuit against
the ufc if you don't have people don't
have any freedom they don't have any
control over the career think about this
every single file in the uc roster and
everybody that's considered signing with
the ufc they need to really
contemplate this if nate diaz can be
disrespected to the media by the
promoter the way that he has been they
don't care about anybody
that's the sad reality but like if nate
wants his release you should get his
release he's had enough stitches he's
made enough money for organization let
him go that means i'm going to make a
bunch of money or fighting jake paul
then so be it even better if you see
have not got their hands in his pockets
i just don't know
like when i woke up that day i saw a
thing about him winning one fight in
five years it made me uh maybe the best
person to fight is jake paul it's just
unnecessary disrespect it's one thing
when you get fighters disrupt one
another because that's kind of part of
the business but when the promoter
starts [ __ ] on people like that
someone like nate diaz who's a cult icon
that just looks bad
i
i can see dan yeah i can see dan hardy's
point i i get what he's saying
especially dana being the promoter you
know
and obviously roger goodell or uh some
of these other guys who never do this
he's [ __ ] on people before but this
doesn't feel like actual [ __ ] just
doesn't feel like [ __ ] and the thing
is
i agree with him where it's like then
let him go but him saying um
uh
i see this isn't disrespecting me so
when i woke up today i saw the thing
about him winning one fight in five
years maybe the best certain fight is
jake paul jake paul is unnecessary
disrespect
well
the one fight in six years is just
pretty black and white and then fighting
jake paul well why did danny even bring
up jake paul
well nate diaz wants to fight jake paul
post a video going let me go so you know
i got work to do
so nate wants the jake ball fight
dana's not throwing disrespect saying
well the only guy nate can beat is the
youtuber named jake paul
well that's not even dana's idea if
i'm sure dan would prefer nate retires
and just stops fighting
nate wants to fight jake paul that's not
even dana's idea so there's no you know
what i'm saying like there's ways you
can [ __ ] on dana he said a lot of things
what you can [ __ ] on but this is
i don't get it i really don't this one i
don't get um
i do agree where if he wants his release
he should get released if you can't find
him a fight if that's a final fight let
him go because he can do the nate or the
jake paul fight like you said
the other thing though is it's a
business and nate did sign the contract
so yeah
so is it okay for the fighter not to
honor the contract what if the ufc
didn't honor the contract
is it cool if we just don't honor
contracts like it's a fun i'm i
definitely think they should release an
idea if he's that unhappy ufc can't find
him fights
dana doesn't need to say this just let
him go and then fight jake paul
but also as a guy who runs a business
if we're just not honoring contracts the
entire business model's [ __ ] so what
if connell has two fights left on his
contract six fight dealing goes i don't
want to do those i won't go fight jake
paul
and if you let natives contract well
that's gonna start that and then
everybody else can like yeah i don't
want to do it either man i'm going to
fight these youtubers and the ufc is
like well [ __ ] man what are we going to
do like
there has to take some responsibility on
nate's party
you did sign the contract though my man
like there's something with to that you
know yeah
i get both sides it's dicey but also
if i'm the ufc and nate's that unhappy
just keeps you on the business let him
go man yeah
would there even be a way for the
fighters like to come to an agreement of
like giving them money to leave you know
like buying out their contracts you pay
out payouts like giving the ufc money
yeah
yeah it gets dicey too because most
funds don't have that much money and
then also with nate maybe does have the
money it's like all right dana i'm give
you whatever 5 million because i'm going
to pass on the connor fight and go fight
jake it's tough yeah just let him go
dude you know but again for the ufc as a
business
you can't
you can't just let guys out of contract
because that's going gonna start a
[ __ ] snowball yeah
because then every lawyer is gonna be
like well you let nate out
you know so the ufc does have to run a
business
sucks for everybody yeah it's it's a
tough situation for everybody and also
you know dan hardy comes from a
different perspective too you know he
said his issues with dfc they let him go
you know
yeah
all right this is uh pretty sad but
bigfoot fought had no idea he was
fighting over this last weekend but he
keep doing it man he keeps doing it and
he got knocked out he's one in ten yeah
his last one ten and one is last 12
fights
yeah so here's that ko
stuck in the very beginning
56 punches
bigfoot's only thrown five punches
holy [ __ ]
bigfoot russian ninja got caught and
it's just it's tough man i wish he would
stop seven straight loss fifth straight
time he's been stopped god damn these
kids man yeah i hate to see it what else
you got man um let's end on this one
it's kind of a funny one here
not this one right no let's look at
another knockout real quick
if i can find it
okay this is pretty cool knockout oh
just bad timing on homeboy's part
[Music]
welterweight
oh my god oh my god yeah that was a
crazy kick
and so this fighter won over the last
week or the past weekend at the shopkop
fight this guy
i find him super funny so check him out
why he looks like a combination of
dustin poirier and charles oliveira this
guy must think that dustin and charles
are the two best good looking guys ever
so thank you
i understand when people say foolish
things to promote themselves but this
guy is pretty idiotic
i haven't said anything idiotic when i
talk trash it's not trash talk it's fact
talk when i say ego sucks that's a fact
i'm not promoting anything he does suck
what do you want from me don't take it
up with me take it up with him
who is mr brony talking so much crap i
think you know exactly who the [ __ ] i am
everybody knows who i am by now if you
don't where the [ __ ] you been who are
you
he's colby 2.0 uh no i've addressed this
before i'm not kobe 2.0 he's got a stick
he's fake nothing about me is fake uh
yeah you're a [ __ ] idiot
guy fieri's fit nephew from the jersey
shore that's actually [ __ ] hilarious
that's the best one um props on that
tweet but if i saw you in person i'd
still have to beat the [ __ ] up
wait who is he like seriously i mean
like seriously yeah you know exactly who
the [ __ ] i am but you can plan it on
twitter that you don't know who i am
everybody knows who i am brother
he sounds like eddie alvarez after he
sucked off a helium balloon kind of
funny um again i say that to my face i'm
not a hard guy to find go down to fort
lauderdale look for a guy with a sick
tan great hair surrounded by beautiful
women come stay to my face and we'll see
what happens he's finally so that was
the uh fellato card about ben but yeah
he fought over the weekend that's funny
yeah and he uh did well
yeah yeah something about him danny
sabatello yeah yeah he's not fake is it
yeah he's funny yeah he's fast too yeah
i like him
uh is that it that's it
all right kids there you have it man uh
hopefully enjoyed the show josh emmett
uh chimed in gave us a little breakdown
on the featherweight division and he
thinks he gets the next title shot uh
but you have a big boy
this freaking saturday ufc 276. we are
doing a cowbest fight command that
starts at 7 p.m pacific on the thick boy
network we have some great guests i
can't wait to do this it's been a hot
second since we've done a fight
companion and there can be a better card
to do it the main card man right now you
got four fights you have pedro munoz
sean o'malley sean strickland alex
pierre alex uh volkanovsky max hallway
izzy and jared cannonaire is your main
event uh this is a phenomenal fight uh
my draftkings picks are uh if you do the
click on the tab at the top you get my
uh parlay and my we go back to the main
one thanks dude uh you get my parlay and
my parlay uh will be um listen i will
take
i'm picking it right now i will do izzy
sean o'malley and brian barbarina
is my uh they're gonna boost your parlay
so all three have to win in order for
you to make bank but it will boost your
odds way up so if you bet a hundred you
win you know a few hundred bucks there
but a thousand went even more so um yeah
there you have it izzy sean o'malley and
brian barbarina brian barbarina is the
only dog and he's a minus 105 so it's
not that big of a deal but still
it's robbie lawler she never know what's
gonna happen so enjoy the fights tune in
watch the cowboys fight command on think
boy youtube only that's at 7 p.m pacific
with a great lineup and uh yeah man
enjoy ufc 276 this mother trucking
saturday uh for the trash panda summer
tour we're striking back up in july july
14th through 16th i'm in fort wayne
indiana fort wayne indiana never been
looking forward to it brand new club
july 14th to the 16th san diego is also
in july that's july 21st through the
23rd that's at the laugh factory
downtown san diego baltimore maryland is
august 4th through the 6th appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
and september we have houston in boston
get your tickets at fatkz.com
or sickboy.com but fort wayne indiana
and san diego europe this month july
trash panda summer tour let's ride uh
that's it kids enjoy ufc 276 tune into
the fight campaign 7 p.m pacific live or
you can watch the next day on think boy
youtube be safe enjoy the fights love
you guys i'm out